[Music]
max
is in saint louis hey max how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
hey my grandparents set aside
investments for all their grandkids
they purchased me a hundred shares of
facebook years ago thirty two dollars a
share
today that investment is worth right
around twenty eight thousand
and so my question is should i just
leave it there or should i invest invest
it elsewhere so that it is more
diversified
okay somewhere else where it's more
diversified
yeah i don't own any i don't own any
single stocks
i don't play the market and you are
betting
28 000 on one set of nerds
i mean you are yeah and i don't know
what facebook's going to do
yeah um truthfully social media team has
got
real i mean the i.t or the tech world
has got some real targets on their butt
right now
they've been misbehaving and i don't
know what that's going to result in
but facebook has been screwing with us
in business for a long time we work with
them
but about the time we figure out some
way to utilize that stuff
they figure out some way to charge
double for it i sure did
and um and you know it's it's uh
and truthfully there's a fatigue out
there on social media in general people
are just sick of it
so i don't know i'm not saying that
facebook's going to fail
i'm just not betting 28 000 on their
success
i would rather have that 28 000 in
mutual funds and if they're
if those mutual funds own some facebook
well so be it yeah
if they own some google well so be it
but i don't buy single stocks personally
because i don't like the risk
anthony no dave you said it best you
know and i think
uh listening to max he sounds real young
and he's like man you know that's
facebook though dave you know
and i like what you said it's you're
putting all your money into not just
um facebook but into one group of people
and i think i would rather be
diversified now if you can get it into
facebook and google
uh and and diversifying it then great so
when a company
first issued stock for the first time
it's called an ipo
yep an initial public offering and i was
on the air
when facebook first finished the stock
and it was so hyped that it went through
the roof it was like a gold rush wow it
went
straight up and then six weeks later it
went straight down
because it was overhyped it was not
based on valuation it was just based on
people were just freaking out because
facebook was cutting edge it was so cool
in those days
everybody was believing it was the big
deal and it is a big deal obviously
uh they're they're have become a world
player without a doubt
yeah but the uh uh but i i mean i
and people said don't you didn't you buy
in on the ipo nope i did not
i did not because i know i hype when i
see one
and um single stocks will get you bit so
that's what that's that's what we
wouldn't do
and hey thank you for the call